the supreme court is judging its first
major gun rights case in more than a
decade the justices heard arguments
yesterday challenging a new york state
law that could be a game changer for
many concealed carry laws nationwide jan
crawford is outside the supreme court
with more on this story jan good morning
to you good morning gail you know this
case really pissed a person's right to
carry a gun for self-defense against new
york's interests in limiting the number
of guns in some public places now new
york will let you carry a concealed gun
for self-defense but you've got to have
a permit for that and to get one you've
got to prove that you have a special
need for it and that is different than
the law in 43 other states where it's
actually easier to carry a gun outside
the home for self-defense this case came
about after two men in upstate new york
didn't get the concealed carry permits
that they wanted they said that was
unconstitutional and yesterday a
majority of the supreme court justices
seemed to agree but they divided along
these liberal conservative lines listen
here to uh conservative justice samuel
alito he appeared sympathetic to the gun
owners and then take a listen to liberal
justice stephen breyer who appeared not
to be
but the people
all these people with illegal guns
they're on the subway they're walking
around the streets but the ordinary
hard-working law-abiding people i
mentioned no they can't be armed but
here when you have a self-defense just
for whatever you want to carry a
concealed weapon
you go shooting it around and somebody
gets killed
now this court hasn't really offered any
guidance in this area since it ruled
that the second amendment protected a
person's right to have a gun for
self-defense so this case could have
important guidelines for other gun
regulations nationwide tony
and the second amendment debate
continues jan thank you very much